Albert was a shining God of Comedy he
was speaking directly to me always
something just different he was like a
comedic tornado just fearless and funny
he's so hot it took this to
finally your
accompl can't wait till I'm dead so
here's the thing we've been friends for
like almost 60 years I've always looked
up to you and what you could do with
comedy I did aund variety shows Albert
Brooks Albert Brooks Alber Brooks Albert
Brooks
this this isn't me you're the only guy I
know who would go on national television
with a routine that you had never tried
out I went in the bathroom I would come
up with something and I would go do it
not only don't you have any money but
your sister is dead that was
funny he was the first alternative comic
I think of him as the caviar of Comedy
this guy is really special you're Albert
Brook cut it he's so good you can't
steal
it if you stole it you wouldn't know
what to do with it I mean he's a
beautiful actor he has all that
technique he can do anything and I'm in
love with
you how do you like
that I buried the
lead Stanley cubert called me and said
this is the jealousy movie I've always
wanted to make you've heard of a no- win
situation haven't you Vietnam this I'm
telling you they're around I think we're
in one of them everything he was talking
about is what television turned into
film the
gynecologist what you didn't want to
happen watching an alert Brooks movie
you never wanted the scenes to ever end
Defending Your Life was one of the most
insightful films I'd ever seen hi how'
you die on stage like
you to me genius is you have the idea
and then the courage to execute it I
would rather have Albert's career than
my career I mean I'm listening to all
this and I'm getting a person who's been
defending his life every goddamn minute
yeah my agent said I don't know why you
always take the Hard Road you think I
see two roads I see one road because
this this isn't me it's not the real me
this is the real me he's the funniest
man in the
[Applause]
world